بدت القصه من يوم نزلت وحده من عيال نصار
واللي قالها منيره فيديو بالغلط والمجلسنا
بحزه القهوه صورت سواليفنا اشكالنا وحوسه
بيتنا وكل شيء قال بدون مقدمات ويسابق
انذار ثم شرطب ضغطه زر واحده بس
يستخدموا الاجهزه
[موسيقى]
في 2019 مشرط منظمه الصحه العالميه نص
صريح بعدم تعرض الاطفال لاي شاشه في
السنتين الاولى من حياتهم حتى بعد السنتين
كنت تعرضهم للشاشات مقنن وتحت رقابه عليهم
يعني
البرامج هذه تكون برامج مكمله ثانويه مو
الاساسيه اليوم الكارثه اللي تصير انه
الاهل يعتمدوا عليها
اساسي الطفل اليوم بالنسبه له
الايباد انه جلسه على الايباد واللي على
الاجهزه لانه يتفرج هذا شيء اساسي حياته
يشرب وينام ويتفرج
اساسي في اليوم يعني فشار جزء كبير من
حياته وهذا الجزء ايش فيله يعني السؤال
الخطير
دمار
قاعد يصير لازم نفهم منه الطفل اتفاقيه
حقوق الطفل تقول ان الطفل هو اي شخص يقل
عمره عنده 18 سنه
والجانب القانوني عندنا يسمى الاطفال
قصرين واللي هم كذلك اللي تحت سن 18 سنه
لكن كثير مباشر واهم مرحله نقدر نقيس
عليها التاثير ونبني عليها تصور اللي قاعد
يصير حتى لو تنبه بالمستقبل من خلالها هي
مراحل الناس من اول ما يولدون الين قبل ما
يدخلون المدرسه وهذا اللي يسمونها مرحله
الطفوله مبكر
ايوه الطفوله مبكره احنا لما نقول يعني
يمكن الناس بالارقام او شيء مخها هيبدا
يركز اكثر لا تساين هي اول خمس سنوات من
عمر الانسان ليش مهم خليني ابدالك
بالنار والسيكولوجيا مثلا الانسان اول ما
يتولد 20% بس من دماغه يكون اكتمل 80%
يكتمل بعد الولاده واكتمل تحديدا هذه
التمارين في اول ثلاثه سنين يعني انت
متخيل من من انسان مشدوح طيب عنده حركات
عضليه لا اراديه الانسان يمشي ويزحف وينقش
ويتكلم
ويميز الاشخاص ويميز البيئاته تنخيل هذا
النمو السريع اللي يصير يمكن ما نحس فيه
دراسه بحث الجمعيه السعوديه الاعلام
والاتصال تقول الدراسه ان الاطفال الحين
صاروا ينشئون في بيئات اتصاليه كامله
واللي هي البيئات اللي تتكون من ثلاث
اطراف اساسيه الصناع نفسهم المحتوى المقدم
والاطفال كطرف ثالث ومصلي
يلبسونك قنبل وتفجر حالك وليد عادي
هذا من الايباد اللي معه
الاطفال مع هذا النوع من البيئات وهو اللي
بالضبط صار مع منيره بنتنا الصغيره اللي
قلناها بالبدايه لهم كلوضوح صارت ما عاد
تفرق بين تفاعلها ومشاعرها في العالم
الافتراضي والواقعي والتاثير هذا يشمل
الاطفال اللي يصنعون المحتوى واللي
يتفرجون عليه ها ها شجره المال هاو لا
اتناول نفس الطبقي مرتين
[موسيقى]
مني
عشان انا اعطيها فلوس اعطيها راضي تجربه
البسه بالمايكرويف
بغض النظر شعور الطرف الاخر طب لا شكل
البيئه ولا شكل المقالب ولا الادوات اللي
استخدمه هي نفسها اللي متوفره عندنا
فتلاقي الطفل تقريبا هو اتاتش للكل شرحه
يعني تحس ما اعتقافيه او يعني كانت واحده
تقول لي باهت يعني كذا اللون باهت مو واضح
مو واضحه ثقافه شلونك مين انت
وحده تراب طبعا الميل مارست سلوكيات
عدوانيه على اللي حولهم
في هذا الميل ما كان حصرا على الانترنت
لانه رجعنا قبل الانترنت في الستينات
الميلاديه لاحظ ثبوت نظريه التاثير على
الاطفال المحتوى اللي يشوفونا ويتعرضون له
واللي جاءت من خلال تجربه الدنيا بوبو او
بوبو ذولا اكسبيرمنت اللي سواها المختص
البرت بندوره في جامعه ستاندرد سنه 1961
جاب فيها مجموعه اطفال ومجموعه ممثلين
ودميه او عروسه
نصين نص اطفال يشاهدون بعد غين يمارسون
سلك عدواني وتلفظون بشعه والنص الثاني
عكسهم واللي حصل كان متوقع طفل
تطبيق تيك توك تحدي جديد تحدي كسر الجمجمه
اكثر تحديات تيك توك جننونا وخطوره
[تصفيق]
بشكل دقيق وفحص حول نوعيه المحتوى اللي
قاعدين بشكل كبير عند الاطفال ولقوا واللي
فيه العوائل شاركون يومياتهم ينزلون نمط
حياتهم بشكل دوري وهي الاكثر تاثير مشاهده
عند الاطفال وعلى واحده من العوائل اللي
تجوز فيها عدد الاشتراكات 22 مليون مشترك
وكل يوم عن يوم قاعد يزيد يضاع حتى
الاطفال اللي يشوفونهم طلعوا بنتيجه ان
عائله تعزز عند الاطفال الشعور بعدم
الرضاعه المعيشه الحاره
بدنا نعمل تحدي يوم كامل
بالحمام وعلى النطاق المحتويات الثانيه
لاحظنا ان الغالب في محتويات الاطفال
حاليا وجود طرح لمفاهيم ومعايير وعناصر
غير مناسبه للفتره العمريه للاطفال
وممكن تولد عندهم حالات التشتت ضعف انتباه
نتيجه توظيف نوعيات الوان محدده ووصفات
مزعجه وغير متناسقه
[موسيقى]
الا غرفه
امي وابوي يرحم لي
العناصر اللي المفروض تكون موجوده اللغه
الملائمه بسرعه الصوت مره مهمه سرعه
الحركه نفسها في الشاشه رتم الموسيقى هذه
كلها تفرق لان الريتم العالي السريع يعمل
نشاط عالي في الدماغ فممكن اربكو البناء
الاخلاقي عند الطفل يختلف من عمر لعمر
احنا لازم نعرف انه متى الطفل يفهم معنى
الصدق ومتى يكتمل هذا المفهوم عنده هذه بس
على قيمه واحده هيك على القيم ثاني عارف
لما تكون مكينه مثلا المفروض بس تطحن لك
بن وتباها تطحن لك عظم
والان كان ودي افهم ايش قاعد يصير في
بيوتنا بشكل اقرب تحت خط تواصل مع الاهالي
عشان اسمع معاناه عيالهم مع هالنوعيات من
محتوى اللي يشوفونها
اليوتيوب الاوائل ايمان
كثيره
[موسيقى]
ليش احنا مو زي العوائل هذه ما نطلع
اختلاف في تصرفاته الفاظه عنف
احلام كوابيس
مخاوف جديده
الفاظ بذيئه
في برنامج هو مو كرتون بس انه مؤثر صيني
ممكن ممكن يكون صيني
يعني على اليوتيوب مقاطع
في العصير وبدل ما يشربها من
بره
كل سؤال بالي كان يجير وراء الف سؤال اذا
كان ها الاثر بيلحق منيره وكثير اطفال لنا
اخر يوم بحياتهم وممكن بعدين يلومون
لحالهم وش ممكن نسوي عشان نحافظ على
العيال اليوم بكره ولو كان بشكل نسبي شوفي
انا في منهجيه مره احبها في البنت بشكل
عام في الصحه النفسيه اللي دكتور
ريتشاركوهن يقول ان احنا العافيه النفسيه
زي الكرسي اللي انت جالس عليه الكرسي اللي
انت جالس عليه له اربع رجول وظهر تخيل انت
جالس على الكرسي ماله رجلين
بالضبط او عشان لا تطيح هتحط كل ثقلك على
هذه الرجلين وهذا اللي بالضبط يصير احنا
عندنا جزء عاطفي اجتماعي معرفي عقلي وجسدي
بعد اخذ وعطاء وتواصل كنت اتوقع ان اسئلتي
ممكن توقف او تخوفي قل او يكون معي حل او
نصف حل الاني اكتشفت مع الوقت انها
التفاصيل ضمنيه وما حد يقدر يلزم فيها الا
بعد عشر سنوات عشان يوضح اثرها فهل وجود
محتوى ضمني سيء اثرها غير واضح او غير
مباشره
بسوي فيه حتى لو غلطت طفل
يعني مثلا خلينا نقول انه احيانا عندنا
انظمه تكون مختلفه عن الانظمه اللي في دول
ثانيه
مقياسنا دائما اذا كان في ضرر او محتوى
مخالف للانظمه مخالف الاحكام الشريعه ممكن
احنا نقول هنا في قسنا نوع من انواع الذره
اللي لازم يوقف هذا الشخص عند حضرتك ولكن
طالما مسبح وما وصل للمرحله الجرميه او
المخالفه النظام كل اللي يفعله يعتبر
صراحه سليم يعني شخصيه تسوي مقالب
سخيفه يعني فكان واحد يقول هو سيكولوجست
امريكي كان يقول له هذا الراجل جاء دق باب
بيتك ويقول لك اقعد مع طفلك ساعه واحده في
غرفه لوحده هل تسمح له
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه هو بيجلس مع ولدك ساعات بس من
خلف الشاشه لا تقل الخطوره من خلف الشاشه
عن
الحضور وحاضر بحيات